I get people who claim at least claim
that they were inspired by UFOs or they
have tapped in just on their own to the
same
physics that they're operating by and
they have some technology and they want
to show me but I have this policy of I'm
sorry if you can't come public with it
like show everyone then don't show it to
me because I don't want to have any
information that I can't talk about so
that's just my own policy I don't like
to have to sign an NDA or be in
possession of anything that I can't talk
about and what they tell me is Kurt as
soon as I go forward with this I will
people have died from this the
government has silenced people and I'm
worried for my health my safety or I've
been contacted by the government
officials who are trying to silence me
so in other words those are some fears
that people have now I'm curious do you
have those fears and how warranted are
they
they're very warranted and we can prove
that this has happened I mean I've been
personally involved in teams that have
had the result of a wet Works group kill
its principal people what works is cie
term for wet from blood being killed and
you know I've had myself on the watch
group list more than once which is the
kill list but I think that what how do
you know that sorry I don't mean to
interrupt I just thoughts occur to me so
how was it disclosed to you that well
you remember I'm starting in 93 I
briefed people like the director of the
CIA and I have a network of people in
clandestine services and elsewhere who
uh you know
who are friendly to what we're doing
they want to stick their necks out too
far because they don't end up like Bill
Colby the CI director who is helping us
back in the 90s bring one of these
Technologies out and they found him
floating down here south of DC in the in
the river
um he was wet work his best friend was a
colonel who was on our team and
confirmed that that was a kill but made
to look like an accident so these guys
are not without Foundation what they're
they're huge mistake and this is a big
part of this film and you're going to
hear about this if you join our podcast
on October 25th
there is a strategy to avoid that but
everyone keeps making the same mistakes
and as Einstein said with you know
definition of insanity is doing the
thing same thing over and over expecting
a different result so what we've done is
analyzed 120 years or so of these sort
of Technologies how they've come and
then how they vanished what are the
mistakes that are consistently made and
you named it you hit the nail on the
head they're trying to keep it secret
now you know what I tell people is that
if you have something like that contact
me yesterday
um immediately and that you have to be
prepared to open source it now what does
open source mean it's like GitHub the
software company it means that you
release all of it without any holdback
to the public but massively so what I
would do is have a massive
press conference around it but it would
have been released
the entire plants how it operates
nothing held back forget patenting this
stuff it's going to get seized
um to a national security order NSO and
so what you have to do is is say okay
the the whole system is set up
to intercept these the big one of the
biggest ones are financial and legal
traps uh that are out there because
people taking quote investors the other
is that you'll be offered a lot of money
be black shelved I mean if it's enough
information and knowledge they'll
they'll try to buy it off and and put it
on a shelf where nobody sees it
that we know specific cases where that's
happened well that person is Rich the
inventor and his team but you know the
world's dying right right so now there
is another way to do this but it's very
against what most venture capital and
financial and legal and business people
would say and that is you take all the
details of that invention
and you release it open source and
without any holdbacks no patent for the
good of humanity yes but it would also
be for the good of the person I'll get
to this in a minute this is very
counter-intuitive and this is where you
have to you can have a a 100 million
dollars in an operational device but if
you don't strategically understand what
you're up against you're up against uh
800 trillion 900 trillion dollars uh
cartels of energy utilities oil gas coal
all of this uh the petrodollar system
you're not going to take that on even if
someone gives you a billion dollars if
you don't have the right strategy so
what I explain to people is that what I
what I discovered from working with a
number of these groups beginning with
Bruce De Palma in 1991 and subsequently
the tuari device and many others and the
Stan Meyer family that had the car
running on water those were real systems
but they all made the same mistake they
kept the the technology Secret in a
small group of people so I recommend you
have to do something called detargeting
how do you detarget yourself well you do
what I've done you get it out there you
put it out there and uh that's what I do
with the disclosure project you don't
sit on this sort of thing because if
nobody knows here's a tree that fell in
the woods that nobody ever heard right
so if you don't want to be the tree that
falls in the woods which means another
dead body or a confiscated technology
you push it out here's one of the
problems if you're in a lab at Lawrence
Berkeley labs like a man I know who
discovered one of these a physicist
and nobody knows who you are you don't
have the means to get a billion two
billion people aware of it what my group
has developed or groups of influencers
and celebrities and others that we would
be able to get that out to people and
you know at least a billion to two
billion people in a couple of weeks in a
fortnight so what that means is that you
squeeze the toothpaste out of the tube
so fast and so hard these fascists can't
put it back in
sure how do you get it out to let's say
a billion people how do you do that what
is that like a newsletter or a video
about like this is popular this is a few
thousand but no for example you know
there there are people who are very very
supportive of what what I'm working on
like uh Demi Lovato and Ariana Grande
and other celebrities and I you know we
say hey drop this link to your 150
million followers and the link will go
straight to the plan so that everybody
could build one of these who's skilled
in the art of electrical engineering so
you have to get it out why is that
because the group that wants to the
these sort of Nefarious covert groups
who've been keeping these technology
secret they're counting on them
remaining obscure and your obscurity is
your Achilles heel if you don't have a
billion or two billion people who know
about it and you're not going to get
cooperation from the mainstream media
because the mainstream media is corrupt
and we'll ban it it will absolutely ban
the story on it now of course you know
we say well the mainstream media are
ostensibly pro-environmental not on this
I'll tell you a very funny story a
briefing 120 world leaders and on an
island and you're the Great Barrier Reef
uh back about nine years ago and the
most hostile person when I discussed
this I was on a panel with the head of
British Petroleum and a whole bunch of
other people in the Minister of Defense
of Australia was there and a bunch of
other world leaders but the most hostile
person out of that 120 person crowd was
the head of Greenpeace